[Music]
aaron is with us in kansas city hi aaron
how are you
good how are you doing dave better than
i deserve what's up
good
hey i got a question um so i have a
daughter that's getting ready to start
college next year and a son that's going
to be a sophomore in high school
um
i just want your advice um we don't have
debt except for our house
but
you know
we've been blessed last couple years our
pay has increased you know
quite a bit more than like two years ago
but we weren't disciplined enough to
really save much for college um
i don't want my kids going into debt
right and
my question is you know since we've had
you know a bump in our income
should i attack their college
tuition like
it's debt you know what i mean like
she's getting ready to enroll next year
where i don't have to take out any loan
or anything like that because i don't
want to do that or
what what's your
what is your household income
um we're right around
200. okay all right
um
well um you yes you can cash flow this
college um it is based on a couple of
things
um and you're gonna have to do it with a
plan
unlike unlike how you got here right
so um one of the things we know for sure
the biggest element on being able to
cash flow college is college choice
right that debt free college is college
choice when you choose a college when
you choose a bentley
on car lot and you have a chevrolet
budget
you're about to go in debt
right and so you you are not on the
bentley lot my man you're broke you're
broke with a good income
so this young lady is going to a
wonderful state university with in-state
tuition
yeah maybe even yeah maybe even a
community college for the first two
years to get her
uh some of the basics out of the way or
maybe even both right she can do yeah
she
she will have about a year um going into
it and we are going to state school so
um going to live at home
um actually she'll be about two hours
away okay um so
going to kansas going to kansas soon
yeah yes sir okay all right yeah yeah
well i got a jayhawk in my family that's
right
well it's a wildcat oh oh oh you're
going that way okay
yeah yeah
um but yeah we don't you know like i
said we don't have any debt um now it's
just
i was trying to look at this is like
gazelle intensity well how much is how
much has kansas did a year have you
looked it up
yeah um you know she'll get some
scholarship so
with everything around 22 000
um no no it's not 22 000 tuition
no room and border you're talking you're
talking about important yeah i was
asking i'm asking tuition how much is a
tuition oh yeah 9 500. okay all right
that sounds right
and uh and so 22 000 if you if that all
goes in that's 2 000 a month out of a
200 000 income 24 000 a year
yes sir and you cash flow that out of a
thing and that does not even require
gazelle intensity that just requires a
budget item you just have two thousand
dollars a month for college
yeah in your budget
and i would i want to warn you two
things one is
be very diligent about the actual costs
not well yeah you know and you'll get
that fafsa sheet that says here's what
our estimated cost and
watch every dollar just like you do in
your home budget because it can balloon
on you and set up have hard
conversations with your daughter about
she has to work for spending money or
she has to work for laundry money or
whatever those things are have very firm
conversations and remember this
the entire there's an entire industry
based on parent guilt when it comes to
college choice
yeah and it's like dave said except they
get a bunch of cool attractive young
people who will take young people to the
bentley lot
and then talk about and drive them
around and give them a great experience
and then they'll send the kid back to
mom and dad and say mom if you loved me
you'd get me this car right
and you guys screwed up and didn't
handle your business right
this is the car i should be driving this
is what everyone's gonna drive to get to
where we're gonna go i need you to know
that that you're you're
you're being preyed upon don't fall
victim to that ksu is a great college
your kid can do great things from that
school but go in with a firm plan don't
buy into any of that guilt nonsense okay
so we're watching stuff like the
cafeteria plan
yeah what's it cost what's it entail and
oh by the way if we're gonna get the one
where you eat there all the time you're
gonna eat there all the time kiddo and
have a hard conversation i had this with
a buddy of mine recently who's a
physician whose kid was about you know
almost gonna lose a scholarship have the
conversation now if you lose your
scholarships
you will come home you will go to
community college have all that now so
it's not drama later on down the road so
everybody's clear right
and that lack of clarity is what got you
here in the first place so let's do
something different this time real
detailed plan we'll send you a copy of
the book um that free degree that'll
show you how to walk through it and i
recommend you sit down with your uh with
your teen and your spouse and watch
borrowed future tonight yes it's the
documentary that we did on
student loan debt and how epic out of
control stupid it is
and uh it's several hundred thousand
people have viewed it you can watch it
on google play or apple tv or on amazon
prime easy enough you can just rent it
for the nice like three bucks whatever
the documentaries are right now 399
whatever it is and so you can watch it
john's
is featured in it as one of the people
and uh it'll just it'll scare the
bejesus out of you about student loan
debt and cause you to really focus on
this plan and so yes you can cash flow
this but it's all about choices
it's all about choices it's all about
choosing to be a grown-up we are not
paying for a degree in beer pong
you are going there to study
pass your dadgum classes
show up to class there's an amazing
correlation between people who show up
to class and those are pass yeah it's
really strong amazing correlations you
follow the syllabus that graduate in
four years because you it's all it's all
laid out yeah and and the classes are
all available for you to graduate in
four years they're all right there
nobody tricks you
you just have to go check box check box
check checkbox checkbox checkbox you are
managing a project and this project is
four years long and this is what we're
gonna do and uh well i'm not i'm not
that doesn't sound very fun this ain't
about fun darling that's about getting
your education yep if you want if you
want fun join a country club go to the
fair
um this is not it's not about fun
go to the fair because it's suddenly
1808 right
hey kids go to universal i don't care
but um
hey kids go to the fair let's go
let's play let's let's take the cow they
do have funnel cakes in the shop and the
uh the little shut up goldfish toss 1808
1808
you have been at the fair and you were
not even thought
at the fair i love it leave me alone
funnel cakes i saw merle i did i saw
marlo haggard at the home depot but that
doesn't mean
all right so that's the thing it's all
about choice john has a phd in higher ed
uh so he actually knows how to answer
these questions and that's one of the
reasons he was interviewed he was
actually interviewed before his ramsey
personality yeah for that documentary
and
that documentary is blown up it is
causing a holy ruckus there are some
people in higher ed not happy with
ramsey
because we kind of told the truth about
what a screw job some of this is and
certainly the people that sally may and
navient don't like us because we expose
their misbehavior we also called
congress a bunch of fools but we've been
doing that for 20 years so that ain't
nothing new i think it's good to point
out like this father here
yeah
you will pay for it at some point you'll
pay for it by when you're young and
you're putting money away for college
or
you're gonna not be able to pay your
house off in baby step six because
you're gonna cash flow college if that's
what you choose to do but again it's
gonna cost you at one end of this
spectrum or the other so if you can plan
for it ahead of time it's kind of like
christmas you know people every year
people are surprised oh gosh they move
it they're right your kid's gonna turn
18. have a plan and start having that
conversation it's going to happen yeah
and you know we had the conversation
about a lot of things like where you're
going to go to school
and uh well you just want to discuss
because you went there no it's not
because i went there i mean you can go
to another in-state school if you want
to go for that one yeah but i mean any
of them that are in state i'll pay for
it but um but you know in-state tuition
but you know one of them thought they
were going to go across the county line
down here into another state it was
fourteen thousand dollars more a year
i'm like who's paying for that
they're like well uh oh oh oh so what's
no difference is just they're both the
school yeah you're going the one up here
is cheaper this is not a hard
conversation here
gee this is the ramsay show